-We're here with Bill Murray,
Dan Aykroyd, Ernie Hudson.
You were saying,
you think Danny maybe has
a little too much energy.
-Just on behalf of the audience,
which is a great
New York audience and
everything, you have this --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Eh, cut that crap.
[ Laughter ]
New Yorkers don't do that.
We cheer about, like --
"Oh, I'm from --"
We don't do that.
But we have this great
Nate Smith,
who is a fantastic drummer.
And I think you would be
robbed and cheated
if you didn't get a little bit
of a just a short drum solo
from Nate Smith with Dan Aykroyd
dancing in front of Nate Smith.
Wouldn't you want to hear that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go ahead, Dan.
[ Drum solo ]
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, sir.
-Now, we need --
Just so the audi--
Now, Nate, you've never met
this man, correct?
-No.
-Not a planned situation.
When did you --
-Nate, you're very good, too.
[ Laughter ]
-That is -- I mean,
that's one of the secret --
many secret hidden talents
of Dan Aykroyd.
When did you know that Danny
was the funniest
comedy dancer of all time?
-Well, when he started going out
with this girl Rosie Shuster.
The two of them were the
two worst dancers I'd ever
seen in my life.
They're both Canadians and
really dangerous,
and they wore
big shoes and boots.
And they got a lot of speed up,
a lot of centrifugal force
that they could not control.
And so you'd have to go like,
"Okay, where are they?
Okay, good.
Let's just keep moving
this way."
You'd have to sort of
counterclockwise from them
in order to not get hurt.
-Yeah, well,
you could see there was a
sense of danger there
as we watched that.
-Yeah.
-You know, I think,
based on knowing your work
from other things
when I saw "Ghostbusters,"
I was at the age
where I was happy
that it was a film
that I could go see as a kid.
Was the plan from the beginning,
when you were working on it,
Dan, to make it
a kid-friendly movie?
-Oh, I think it was
to be a comedy for everybody.
And, obviously, you know,
we watched the profanity in it.
I don't think there -- There
might be one bad word in it.
But, no,
we were conscious of that
and knew that we would have
a young audience.
And, today,
we have an audience of, like,
grandchildren and
even great-grandchildren
of the original viewers
that are watching it.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You all have kids.
Were your kids fans of
this film?
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Absolutely, sure.
-And I'd assume
that matters, right?
Like, I would assume
it's a huge bummer
when your kids
don't like the movie,
especially when you
make it for kids.
-Well, they didn't buy
the merch.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But they liked the movie.
It was economical
Halloween costumes.
You know, "Well, I got this.
You want to wear this?
"Okay."
Yeah, they really did like it.
But it was nice to have a movie
that kids could see.
You know, we're not really --
You know, we just don't --
We're like you, Seth.
We don't work blue.
-Thank you.
Thank you for acknowledging
that in my work.
We were talking backstage that
you have, over the years,
met people who have tattoos
of you both from
the "Ghostbusters"
and other work.
And do we want to check.
Anybody here have a
"Ghostbusters" tattoo?
Okay, well, it's not your night.
-"Blues Brothers"?
"Blues Brothers" is another one.
-Yeah.
-And the Conehead.
I've seen him.
-You've seen a Conehead?
-Is there anyone that
has a tattoo
that looks like any one of us?
-Tom Selleck?
Any celebrity tattoos at all?
-Nobody has Tom Selleck?
He thought Tom Selleck -- No?
No one?
-This is a thing.
People do tattoo, you know,
famous people on their --
-You -- I heard a friend from
a story -- sorry --
a story from a
friend of ours that you were
on a golf course in Spain,
and a man from
town heard you were there
and ran to the golf course
to show you what?
-To show me a tattoo
of myself on his leg.
Yeah. And, you know,
when a man in another language
starts running at good speed at
you, you know, I'm like,
"I don't know.
How far away is he?
Do I hit him with a 4-iron
or do I hit him with a wedge?"
So -- And then I didn't know
what to say except,
"Mucho gusto."
It was -- it was -- I was happy.
-I'm sure that
meant the world to him.
-But, you know,
it turns out not everybody
in the town of Chinchón is
wearing a tattoo of myself.
-He was the Bill Murray guy.
I'm sure the word got to him.
Like, "You got to show up
to the golf course now."
What was it like --
Do you remember
your first experience
meeting each other?
Did you meet at Second City
or did you meet at "SNL"?
-Well, I had a partner,
Valri Bromfield,
and we had a comedy act that
we were working on,
like, kind of a Nichols and May
kind of improv thing.
We got hired by Second City.
And we swapped companies with
the Chicago company.
The Toronto company
went down to Chicago,
and Chicago went to Toronto.
And our guide when we arrived in
Chicago was Bill Murray,
who met us, took us around,
got us settled in apartments,
and showed us the grocery stores
and the local bars.
And at that time, I think you
were in the touring company.
But he was -- You know,
he welcomed me to America,
where I got my first H-1
and my work permit.
And Billy was there as
my sponsor, so...
-Well, that's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you -- Ernie,
do you remember the moment
after making this film that you
realized it was a giant hit?
Was it immediate?
-No. I think, you know,
it came out, it was a hit,
and that was --
You know, that was what it was.
But I think it was 5, 10 years
later that fans kept coming up,
kept, you know,
putting on the jumpsuits,
turning the cars into
Ectomobiles,
showing up at my house
that I realized
that this was something
really, really different.
-Yeah.
-Well, it's incredibly special.
And I really want to say
again, you know, I --
Not just a film that I enjoyed,
but a film --
You know, the first one.
I just really remember
the experience
of going to see it
in a movie theater
and how exciting that was.
And it's really cool that
this new movie is coming out
at a time where people
can do that again.
-I'm telling you,
I believe, truly,
that people are gonna go to
"Afterlife,"
they're going to walk in,
they're gonna see it,
and they're go right outside
and line up again,
just like the old days.
That's how good it is.
[ Applause ]
-Does it -- I know you've been
back in the building,
but is it --
Do you have old flashbacks
coming back to 30 Rock?
-Yeah, I remember
sneaking in and out
of this building all the time.
You know,
you'd try to avoid someone
that would make you go to work
or someone that was trying to
grab you after work.
I knew all the secret exits
out of this place.
And now when I walk down
the halls, I think,
"There's no one
following you, Bill.
You're okay. You're safe."
-We made it clear --
And I want to stress this.
We made it clear
with all security,
"Mr. Murray
is not to be followed.
By his request."
I can't tell the
three of you how much
it means that you
spent time with us today.
Thank you so much
for being here.